the mayor of Jerusalem is being hailed a
hero after wrestling to the ground at
Palestinians a suspected of stabbing a
Jewish man near baccata
says he ordered his car to stop when he
saw the attack in the city centre on
Sunday where police have arrested an 18
year old man the 27 year old victim is
still being treated in hospital we spoke
to the journalist Dan Eisenberg who's in
Jerusalem our mara was very
matter-of-fact about what happened he
actually held a press conference less
than two hours after he tackled the
terrorists and explained that he was
driving with his security team to the
office to City Hall the attack actually
took place two blocks away from that
point and he saw from his car window
from an SUV window a man attacking a
group of pedestrians including a
ultra-orthodox man was stabbed in the
abdomen
he said he immediately got out of the
car and began making a beeline to the
terrorists to tell him to stop and at
this point you can see in the videotape
as well Barca is well ahead of his
security team and they did run to catch
up to him when they did catch up to him
and he was maybe 2 or 3 metres away from
the terrorists one of his bodyguards
through a side arm and pointed it at the
es suspect who dropped the knife and at
this point you can see barakat tackled
him to the ground which yeah I would
imagine it's not a common sight among
mayors from major international cities
one thing that needs to be understood
right off the bat for context is that
near Barakat is a war hero he was a
leader of a Elite Guard super unit
during the first Lebanon War he was shot
during the war and he served for six
years this is
man who's a complete stranger to hand in
hand combat and people know that about
him most of the drills leaders in fact
many of our prime ministers and
presidents our war heroes including
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu so
it's understood that the leaders are
quite capable physically so I think that
no one is terribly surprised I think
that they found it amusing if that's the
right word that barakat took it upon
himself to take this terrorists down but
I don't think anyone was shocked by it
which may be one of those things that's
only in Israel